i stayed up late uh watching ted ted
talks you guys know what ted talks are
those
yeah they're fun see
a bunch of grown-ups loving on ted talks
that's kind of my point their powerpoint
lectures given by smart people and
that's
listen that's what i did
electively
last night that's what i chose to do i
have video games i have alcohol
i have every episode of the simpsons but
instead i threw on pjs curled up in the
corner of my couch and got my learn on
i wanted to learn for leisure
learning
because adults love learning it's
something about being a grown person so
school i've been thinking about this
school should be for adults why is it
for kids kids hate learning
why are we wasting school on kids when
eventually as adults they'll want to
learn why don't we just wait why don't
we just let the kids run around like
idiots all day
mouth the gape and let the grown people
learn about plate tectonics
you don't need plate tectonics as a kid
you need bubbles
a butterfly net
and a red rimmed mouth from too many
popsicles
why are we telling these spazzes about
plate tectonics
sit down supply check plate tectonics
i want the card that says scoffing plate
tectonics i want that card
i'm just saying everyone says kids are
so curious so curious they're naturally
curious
yeah not really
kids aren't playing in the mud because
they want to learn about how soil is the
bedrock of life they're playing in the
mud because it's mud
wet dirt
they love it they don't need the back
story
they just want something that looks like
chocolate and poop thank you mud
just a job
schools would be for adults adults we
read we read for fun kids don't read for
fun kids hate reading why are kids
reading the great gatsby anyway
that happens all the time giving junior
high kids the great gatsby they don't
understand the yearning and unrequited
love of two upper crust 30-somethings
what do these kids know about lost did
you one time who lost my favorite hat
and couldn't find it i couldn't find it
looked i look i gave up looking because
i'm a dumb
mom will find it and then she found it
so you know i understand what old jay
gatsby was going through
go chase a dog you
books are for me for grown people
even gym class kids don't need gym class
their bodies are invincible
you know who needs gym class
me
grown-up petey needs gym class
but he doesn't have the time i don't
have a mandatory gym hour just built
into my day
but some 12 year old with zero percent
body fat and a lightning fast metabolism
he gets to go outside and play kickball
with his friends every day at noon
meanwhile i'm withering away at my desk
muscles atrophying under the fluorescent
lights put me in school i'm dying
here's the best part of being an adult
in school if you get a crush
on your teacher as an adult and she
likes you back
you can go out have a few drinks and
straight up miss palermo
that's a perk her
the chain on her glasses
jangling on the bed that's covered in
lesson plans get things out of here
you can look at one like oh there's a
quiz thursday
and it won't be one of those student
teacher sex scandals the only time it'll
be in the paper is when you announce
your engagement